[Music]
everybody going
in wake up early in the morning press
play and let's get it in cause we
rocking with the fighter and he
[Music]
all right let's do it jenna what is that
on the what
what's up hey mysterio mask what the
hell
dude i didn't tell you this someone um
tell us
okay i'll tell you right now so someone
actually
you know how that thing was on the skull
that thai skull someone messaged me goes
dude you have to take that off that's
such bad luck
right when all this [ __ ] happened oh
interesting yeah like it's some sort of
thai thing yeah i don't know wait the
wrong stereo yeah it was on a skull
it was on this like thai skull that we
have out there yeah and then literally i
took it off
i don't even know where we got that so
good off the skull yeah i took it off as
soon as you message because it felt so
real
so this mask is it's like what voodoo or
something like no not that
oh skull but then putting that on the
skull was
supposedly bad round upon yeah damn
that's a razor
ground [ __ ] it's an official ring and
that's when all that [ __ ] happened 619.
oh all the [ __ ] that happened with the
whole you know so it's [ __ ] chin's
fault basically
no you're like that's that's that's
that's famous fault that's why brian's
not here
damn wait that was creepy so i took it
off immediately that is weird shout out
to that person
probably from thailand or what uh i
don't know but
it was a long thing about the why you
shouldn't do this yeah
damn so i took it off we could have used
yesterday
so that's that well what can you do man
what can you do i watched mortal kombat
last night
anyone seen mortal kombat yet he has you
saw what you think so i love not yet no
i loved it it's good i mean you gotta i
mean it is you know take it for what it
is yeah
it's more combat yeah like if i would
have went to theater like the took the
fam
got a babysitter and [ __ ] not that kind
of lit
no but for what it is i don't think you
could make mortal kombat like this it's
not
for the storyline it's for the
fatalities it's for the blood it's for
the [ __ ] they do a good job like
referencing the video
game like the moves and then fatalities
yeah yeah which i love
yeah i grabs a mortal kombat baby dog
yeah mortal kombats
down down stop back back this is what i
want to know you think when you went to
the arcade you know there's that older
dude who is a beast at all the games
yeah all the movies all the fake dollies
where did he learn and he was doing it
at the argentina
think about it there's no forums there's
no internet yeah how the [ __ ] did he
figure that out
he's at home there's no book at home
when it's loading they they have like
the hit list the list and stuff like
that you can go back
yeah you're supposed to hit like certain
things at the arcade because i know at
home like it's a little bit easier you
can practice
at home you can act there's actually
fatality mode and they show you how to
do the fatality
and even then you'd watch them like oh
my god i'm not doing that yeah you would
have to hit so many
buttons i didn't get in my tied in a
fake towel
that's kind of late hey you know what i
said
to the game how did they know though how
how did they know how to do them
did you ever think about that they were
like damn right are you late dawg
you know what pissed me off about
fatalities is when you be pressing back
back a b
and you get too close
yeah you have to be a certain distance
some guys for a different fatality have
to be really far really close
scorpio that's like yeah you got to
stand a certain how the [ __ ]
how did the guy get those older vets of
the arcade figure i used to play mortal
kombat trilogy which was on playstation
and it was easier to like i had i had
this code where i could just unlock
everything
to where i would just hit one button
fatalities see that
that's that cheat code i'm talking
arcade
joystick
i'm not even trying to play mortal
kombat on [ __ ] an arcade i used to
print my cheat codes out on the paper
and just try to like have it on my lap
and just try to do all the faith
yeah yeah yeah exactly that's the real
they have a homie right
write it down dude and you do you do
those fatalities that's like wearing
bottle surface in the club
yeah it was lit you were like god damn
absolutely the only video game there was
no girls in there but still
almost like damn no like girl oh girl in
the arcade
girls there's nobody you got the right
yeah i got i got i got the right
bart's ending
christian over here walking that mr d
the movie is good though the movie's
[ __ ]
good i told you yeah for what it is
they try to play scorpion though i like
how they try to hold wait so
does it revolt like the old ones they
revolve about luke kang
do they revolve off an individual on
this one well it's a new
scorpion it's a new scorpion like you
you have you scored that
yeah yeah yeah yeah have you played the
latest ones and he's like a new
yeah he's a different type you know you
don't have like the uh
and then i didn't like sub zero with the
shoulder pads yeah i like him
i don't know he was a badass but i
didn't like how his shoulder pads went
up to him
he looked like a stingray sub-zero yeah
his head just started here i didn't like
that they had shanks
and everything oh there's no
yeah they do yeah that's that's how
sub-zero looked in the movie
no no keep going now do that right right
there
right there chin which one oh no not
like kind of not this one
no i wish you looked like
he was an injustice the the injustice
game that was fire
they have order combat characters and
injustice uh a couple of them yeah like
uh i'm not an uh mortal kombat guy but
they had like uh i think
uh raid yeah his name is raiden you're a
minecraft
guy no you're too young for mortal
kombat
uh like it was when i was when i was
like uh you're born 98
yeah yeah when i was like 10 to 16 more
combat
was like the game that everybody there's
like mortal kombat
nba jam madden yup yeah i grew up on
trash bandicoot
i grew up all right it's back doug
it is i downloaded it from my son he's
like what is this i'm like what is crash
bandicoot was actually a really fun one
it was hard i like that one dude it's so
hard yeah wait
even even at 38 years old that game is a
beast
no on the on the [ __ ] uh the game
kids have the nintendo switch okay
it's the game's legit it's [ __ ] it's
better than the way better
but you forget how hard it is that [ __ ]
they like mario like my son will
dominate mario
crash bandicoot like dad can you beat
this level like bro
let's see that cracker barrel you get
those yeah oh my god i can't play mario
to save my [ __ ] life
really that game is so hard like like
like cars or just
like like uh the [ __ ] the regular
regular mario
yeah yeah when i was when i was in
kansas city the comedy club of kansas
city they have uh in the green room they
have
it's set up to where it's constantly you
have all the nintendo games or whatever
those earlier video games you want to
try mario and i
bruh it's so [ __ ] hard everybody in
the grapple was trying
to yeah if you have a touch of
[Applause]
uh like tiger go to bed and then his
mama falls asleep and i'm like
let me figure this [ __ ] level out
dude i'm up hours
tiger wake up i'm like wake up dog yeah
like six hours wake up doug
i beat that leg to the next level yeah
yeah you got that here we go damn you
remember spyro the dragon remember that
one
uh no that uh purple that little purple
dragon that was a horrible oh yeah yeah
i didn't play that one
but i know the game yes it was hard
there's also you know you're way too
young for you
donkey kong no donkey kong 64 was lit as
fast
it was hard oh yeah that right there i
remember spyro but there was um
what double golden eye gold knights
so that's real low and the the gun would
miss you that's the key
when you used to play multiplayer that
game was lit as [ __ ] yeah playing a game
yeah uh yeah have you guys ever played
uh castlevania
contra who daft jam jeff jackson oh my
god
yeah no fight for new york is the best
one yeah wait hold on
new york is the best one they have all
the rappers in it what are you talking
about
fight gaming could be dmx yeah ludacris
yep icon was trash though fjm icon was
awful
i haven't remembered that remember 50
cent had a game uh get rich and die
trying
to you had to do all like some good
stuff i actually bought the game
my boy my boy was at um goodwill and he
saw it for like
five dollars and he bought it that makes
sense the game was like terrible but it
was like dope at the same time because
it was like 50 cent it was
all it was like he was like in the
middle of the year it was [ __ ] that
he would think
you played nfl blitz i'm a hockey kid i
played nhl 2003 hits those are fun
me and my brothers and fifa and we'd be
on the same team it would just light the
scoreboard up yeah
and rugby yeah that's funny i never
played the nfl
i actually no i think i did play you've
never gotten to madden or blitz i played
madden a couple times i think i played
blitz when i was younger yeah ricky
williams on the front cover and cordell
stewart yeah
i played i like i said i played like
from nhl 2003 i i have from manhattan
2003 to nhl 201 did they have
any version of like the blitz or nba
street for nhl yeah they had the 2003
hits they had on and is that like three
on three it's
they have like a whole like three on
three like like in the newest one they
have like a three on three like online
mode where it's basically men's week
where it's it's like three and three
like it's an empty ring it's so much fun
but yeah
2003 hits was like it was just
ridiculous you
run into someone the guy does a backflip
like it was like roller hockey
it was so fun your guy catches on fire
if you're starting to like
would you just go to arcades
how much older you think i am 44. played
all the same games you don't remember
shinobi
no ninja stars oh you remember ninja
gaiden
uh yeah yeah yeah i played all those red
ninjas
[ __ ] yeah hey double dragon this guy
right here double dragon was awesome
he's he's a 2k legend oh yeah i mean
he'll get downloaded
nfl 2k no nba hey ask jay
ask your [ __ ] friend jay yeah how i
was at nfl 2k
i no i'm not even exaggerating dog
i never lost you you know who jake's
friend would come over and i beat the
[ __ ] out i don't know who you
know i do i would be dante culpepper i'd
be minnesota vikings
and randy moss and i had a play that was
unstoppable i could backtrack
30 yards and hell man throw a bomb
already i'm talking i
i beat all of jay's older friends every
[ __ ] time
i know someone you can't beat chad john
snoop
no he talking about nfl 2k you talking
about madden oh man yeah
i was pretty good at madame but yeah
i thought that was the one that snoop
dogg was playing nah nah he played mad
no nba these fans know i'll be body and
all these fans oh
you're online online yeah rolly boy yeah
i'm telling you he
he's nice on the stick i haven't lost
now how do you like the 2k yeah i'm nice
in
nba yeah you grown man now though and i
was uh i'm talking i was a teenager
i was a teenager it's girl man in video
games the game
the game i almost got the president
there's a lot of grown man playing you
yeah there's a lot of girls a lot of
kids though yeah
and you're what it is it's all kids
there's not no kids
no no because you can tell like in the
lobby how to uh message you
did you have like an art like i remember
my arcade in aurora it's
actually right next to where the
shooting uh happened was called
aladdin's arcade
my mom would drop can't do this i'd
never do this with my kids my mom would
drop us off there in the summer give us
each 20 bucks
we were there from 9 00 a.m to 5 00 p.m
that was our daycare yeah and i just
watched the old heads with their
fatalities
yeah they don't work like that no more
you can't do that anymore you can't just
drop no more everything's online
now here's here's what's interesting as
a parent if you look up the stats it was
it's more dangerous now than it is back
then
like we think back then was all crazy
yeah now's way more dangerous
i don't even think kids walk to school
even if there's schools i never let my
kid walk to school
damn because we're aware of everything
now yeah
that's gonna be a far ass walkway oh
yeah hours
oh no okay yeah ours was like a
10-minute walk
but we also stayed outside all the time
like we're like
i mean we play video games but we we're
outside all
[ __ ] outside was so funny like when
the street lights turned on we're like
all right better get going that was the
that was the thing that was the thing
they really aren't latch key kids
anymore
what do you mean no latch key kids
basically that like you come home from
school and then your parents are at work
and you just kind of take care of
yourself
you're at the park you're indoors you
just take care of yourself until your
parents get home at like six or seven
yeah
on their phones and [ __ ] everybody cbs
can find out
you know what i mean like if if the kids
like filming themselves at home like
yeah i'm chilling
cps is a [ __ ] they online yeah cps
online
they be lurking more of the story is
mortal kombat's worth the watch
yeah more yeah especially if you're a
mortal kombat head like me and like my
girl didn't grow up on mortal kombat
so any no she did because any time a
character pop up i'd be like oh that's
raden or that's you know kane and i'll
give her the backstory that's sonia did
you like liu kang in there
no thank you so she was saying he was so
i was why was he such an idiot bro i
don't know the whole vibe
bro he messed the whole thing up he was
getting his ass beat he never won
thank you he was like he always just
gets [ __ ] on and that's what i was doing
because the the first uh the first the
first one it was his journey he was your
heart yeah he was like i told my
girlfriend
because she was like because my girl
goes i can't stand that kane guy went
it's weird how they're doing them
because
i do right he's a dope character he's a
beast that's the original bro hey
listen oh no i'm uh bringing up kane
kano oh
i couldn't hang i couldn't stand him in
the movie you didn't like kano no he was
annoying he was
that's he he was like that and we're
gonna pretend sonia can beat him up like
that how long
no matter what the you're looking hey
look at the first one i go to that
uh picture uh wait which is the new cano
that that's the overall
that's the og one that's the one oh
sonya kicks his ass on the right
what does sonya look like in this one oh
she bad she bad
pretty bad
nature they try to give you like some
story and i told my girl my god they
need to quit trying to paint a narrative
just [ __ ] kill each other it's just
literally just a whole two hours of just
two people fighting yeah that's great
but that's what i want from motor combat
me too
yeah i don't want to stop no i don't
know i don't i'm not i mean oh that's
the new sonia
yeah i don't know and all that [ __ ] just
look at that killing click on the
picture yeah right there also
the original was bad like she was a bad
in the original
you remember the street fighter movie
with john claude van damme that [ __ ] was
lit
i remember that one they said he was
coked out on that film oh yeah yeah
he admits it oh he does yeah i'm pretty
sure he does and who's better street
fighter characters are mortal kombat
because you remember that was
always the one that was always the the
debate because like yeah the
the street fighter they're not as like
brutal as a
mortal combat moral combat is just
[ __ ] talk there's a scene in that
where the fatality the girl with the
wings
and he gets on her back oh he get
through his hat and cuts her in half
that was hard that was hard
and he i got to watch it after this that
was luke kane cousin what was his name
uh i forget that's all hbo
oh you know what i was i was trying to
compare i'm sorry tekken versus uh oh
yeah that was hard remember the guy with
that he had like a tiger hat on him
you're the tekken characters oh he uh
more combat versus everybody yeah that
guy that guy yeah that guy
he was my favorite he was he was like
one of the guys you had to unlock though
right yeah dog
i use the i like to use the guy that
eddie yeah known the guy that they used
was similar to the
uh to bruce lee uh right uh oh oh i know
you're talking second characters yeah
he's a tech and character yeah
but i'd say mortal kombat everybody but
that's why i love street fighter he
loves street fighter
this game at the rk you talk about rk's
yeah that [ __ ] was lit
slim did you ever play killer ins this
one was hard though i know it was
a young kid this was hard but again bro
those levels i'm not talking mario hard
yeah
hey
well you weren't here cat but i can't
play mario you can't play mario
mario marshall the one where he runs
straight just regular marcus
yeah my son beat that game hey [ __ ]
adventures you beat all of them
did you ever play killer instinct what's
that i have to see it oh
all right i guess that was just me that
was on super nintendo at home what do
you want to say
i got it on game cast or something i
ain't got it
i never played killer easter you never
played killer oh i have yeah because i
remember the wolf i always liked yeah
that game was this [ __ ]
tough to break in that market when you
got street fighter i know yeah
mortal kombat that was so good more i'd
say more that goes mortal kombat street
fighter
i'll give you that no i got motorcycles
oh really
really i love street fighter yeah second
third
tekken are you serious oh like what are
we shot what are we what are we engaging
off of like the characters are just a
game
fun fact yeah the characters yeah like i
like i'm familiar with street fighter
and mortal kombat world combat's less
no no no let's say i got a combat out of
it i'm talking about street fighter
versus street fighter street fighter
ryu okay okay but we got eddie
what charlie is
with the hair oh he looked like oh oh
that's uh ballarog
barack obama barack obama yeah no barack
obama no barack obama
no bro no you're right barack is street
fighter there he is right there no
go over to john and bison
baraka is a moral combat he's the dude
with the [ __ ] sword arms
yeah yeah yeah brock is the guy with me
and the teeth yeah war wrong that's
all right yeah oh yeah right
[Laughter]
bull riders
video game let's see heavyweight
champion boxing there it is
and it just came out it was like a fight
night now 2004
uh knockout kings yeah that was the main
guy yeah the game was [ __ ] tough
i thought that was
am i tripping kids ain't trying to play
muhammad ali games
look at those graphics those are hard
yeah that was a great game
damn oh wow tyson fury versus hey uh
how was tyson favor been in the game
fight night used to be a heart
night oh my god they need to come back
with that fight night have you played
the ufc game yeah i played it it's legit
especially the new one your boy was a
unlocked unlockable
downloaded character in the huge game
yep really
yup i played the first i didn't know
that i didn't
either so what they had to do you had to
complete the story mode i don't know i
was like a downloadable character if you
you did something damn i think i have
ufc one so i'm gonna look
i know i played it i played that was
hard i was like they tried to compare it
to fight night so i'm gonna
i'm gonna try and unlock the ground
there you go come on
you gotta beat that story mode do the
the green screen
for your moves yeah i got in trouble
because i wasn't on the original roster
for
and then they had me doing this
marketing and i went on the podcast
firing the kid and i
talked [ __ ] about ea sports and oh the
ufc did not like that
all right oh [ __ ] what are you saying
about ea i know can you say it there's a
reason they put me in it they like i was
like [ __ ] like i basically said [ __ ]
yeah sports i got a lot of trouble
i was working for the man at the time um
to be fair ea sports is not all they
they down now
whatever wait don't they they still
produce uh that's it wait so who
produces the uh
they have
nba 2k is a game sport no not not 2k
nba the the the new nba game the one
that you've played
sports mallet yeah nba 2k that's they're
not with us they have ufc they have
madden their fifa
that's it right and then we don't no one
plays nba live
and it's just maddening fifa i mean
they're trying for big boys though they
are
they're [ __ ] up yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah you're right
what i'm saying like uh for you ea uh
not esp game sports has uh
nba 2k damn nba street
[ __ ] yeah they have a new version of
that i download it from my son
they do yeah they have michael jordan in
the game they have you can get all the
like old school players offering me a
street yeah
so it's i think it's two on two it might
be yeah it's two on two because it was
all [ __ ] great yeah that's hard like
i was michael jordan and dennis rodman
and you play this all on your nintendo
yeah
okay yeah i'm about to go it's great you
should get it what's dope is you just
download the game you don't have to buy
the game anymore you just download the
game like when a new game comes out it's
like
35 something just downloading it like an
old or like on a
just one console yeah yeah like we have
like 10 games now we have mortal kombat
on there
and then also like what's dope is they
do updates so like a mortal kombat have
like
sylvester stallone robocop yeah joker's
on there now
so you uh so you don't have to go get
physically getting
downloaded no no gamestop is killing it
now because of the whole stocks
it's backstage but it's not necessarily
like people are going in there to
buy video games i was confused
what's ridiculous now is if you buy the
game you still have to down like if you
buy the physical game
you have to vote so it makes no sense
just download it like yeah like i don't
understand why people
like uh xbox 360 you buy the game you
put it in you can play
you xbox one you go you buy the game you
have to download
like renting like minecraft well i like
there are certain games like i buy the
buy the game for because like i like
like nhl for example like
from 2000 like eight on i like have the
case yeah
this is a classic yeah you have that
yeah and well and the call of duty's too
i mean those are
five i have those yeah i can't play
those games make me sick no
call of duty yeah cause it's all the
[ __ ] running around
after a while you have a certain while
you're too much cardio [ __ ]
no
shirt yes it is that's fantastic one of
my favorite movies all the time it's one
of my favorite movies i like it
i love that movie apparently adam
sandler took his family to ihop and the
lady worked in the front turned him down
yeah wait why i don't know busy so
basically the
uh hostess saw that a man and his family
came in trying to get a table
it was a busy day so they had only a
they had a 30 minute wait adam sandler
basically left but the
hostess didn't realize that it was adam
sandler because of the mask
she noticed later when a co-worker told
her they looked through cc
tv confirmed it was him and people
uh basically saw on tick tock went viral
and they loved adam sandler for not
flexing his celebrity card being like oh
well i'm adam sandler can you see
me now oh wow just so humble i like that
uh mr dee's has a very special spot in
my heart because i
right after i saw the movie i asked out
a girl what year is that
what's up let's see how old chappelle is
that uh that was uh that was
no that was not 2003. mr deeds was um i
remember when i asked her out
it was 2000 2002. did she say yes so you
were saying yes
no i called you on the phone oh man
and 2002 uh 15. so you're 15 you take
this young
philly dove to mr deets i didn't take
her i went with my homies
okay and then after the movie we were
all hyped because it was a good movie
yeah
and then they were like hey man you know
how you like uh such-and-such
what was her name
it's the girl that got me into
cheerleading it's give me something
super no her name's marissa yeah
yeah so i i remember come on now where's
the lopez though
okay yeah that's fine yeah
well she's married now yeah but uh you
definitely aren't looking up your
friends list right now yeah i know
she i remember yeah we were all hyped i
remember we were
uh at our junior high just walking
around we would do that like late at
night just
you guys walk around alert with each
other like hey yeah it was just like
homies man
and then but you liked it yeah because i
i remember i bought her a gift for her
birthday oh damn
i went to the victoria's secret not
fluffy right now
did you get her like the lotion and the
perfume thank you that's what it was see
what i did
every single every single dude with game
would go to victoria's secret and buy
the girl that they like or their
girlfriend the perfume or the lotion
see i thought you were like there's a
thumb
girl you know i wasn't even 15.
oh y'all slow you down no i've always
been like a lover i've never been like
oh
you got some lotion perfume yeah
strawberries and champagne well yeah
yeah and then uh they're like man i
think you've got it
you know what i mean your buddies were
hyping yeah i was like yeah i was like
i got this i think you did yeah so my
homie gave me his phone he had the flip
phone he was the only one with a cell
phone
yeah yeah whatever it was probably and
then uh
i called her up and i was like hey i was
i was wondering if you uh did you just
go right you went right to it
right
uh i was wondering you know if you'd be
my girlfriend
and then she said she's like oh
not right now maybe sometime in the
future and i told my voice i was like
hey doug
she said i don't know i was like
did you guys ever date her no no never
dang no
though uh she's married two kids yeah
she's
killing the game yeah yeah i'm a girl uh
man shoot or shoot though dude that's
how i was though i didn't know
like there has to there had to be a
build up to like when you talk to
someone you got a date you got it like
there's a build-up
but i was just like there was a build up
i don't think you were the only one
you were going on walks around the
[ __ ] school at night not with her
oh
no and then we were like we were just
hyped on the movie because it was so
dope yeah
and they were like hey man you know
because we were sitting we were sitting
at the school in the in the [ __ ]
grass area or whatever and they were
like yo you need to [ __ ] do it man
you need to ask her ain't nothing like
that like got her not like
me like i never i don't even think she
knew i liked her until i [ __ ] asked
because y'all just homies right because
that's how i was i would just ask out
was it awkward on monday when he saw her
no because i'm not an awkward
[ __ ]
you know yeah i mean yeah
yeah you're like
i remember one time i asked a girl and
that i said uh that's in front of me in
math class
she uh i wrote it on a piece of paper i
said hey we'd be my girlfriend what
grade is this
that was seventh grade i remember i
remember she she looked at it crumbled
it up and just [ __ ]
threw it right back in oh yeah i mean
rightfully so she she had every right
today ain't nothing like writing a love
letter
back in the day yeah i was i was just
kidding
so hard for girls i was i'm like just a
lover and then all of a sudden i was
just like oh this and now you got one
now that i was like
yeah one of them talons you ain't let it
go
you said yes
this is okay man i have not messed up
i've asked out 50 women
and narrowed it down to one now i
haven't asked how 50. but i've asked
that a lot
and yeah and did you ask your current
girl out was it or was it just organic
uh no i was like hey will you be my
girlfriend but after how long
uh you guys are going on hikes and shits
and stuff right
anniversary four months four months you
guys were hanging out for four months
yeah yeah that's a good thing
and see at the when i was younger i
thought you was just like oh yeah you
just
if you like a girl you just ask her to
be your girlfriend that's kind of what
you do when you're that young [ __ ] no
at 15. sound like you were asking out
some [ __ ] i know i was especially
like crumpled up the note and threw it
away
i mean she had every right no not really
she could be cool listen i was a [ __ ]
nut
oh you're a while well you weren't
drinking back then though and junior
high yeah i was drinking
come on now you're drinking in seventh
grade yeah first
yeah first you're drinking wild turkeys
dude i'm telling you that's the first
thing i got drunk
out for was wild turkey god dawg yeah
yeah so they're probably
oh yeah yeah they're like oh yeah i
don't know if he's stable for
us yeah and i would get in fights all
the time i was rowdy
i'd cuss out teachers and i'm like and
then i'd be hey you wanna be my
girlfriend
with a victorian secret yeah like this
makes sense
i'm like [ __ ] you miss johnson i'm
leaving i didn't walk out of class
like don't forget your bush
that was the same girl that uh that i
didn't know you're getting hammered off
wild turkey in seventh grade
of course they said no first thing i got
drunk you're a liability
yeah and and then like i remember i
asked to ask this girl to dance to
junior high
it was to that [ __ ] ginger wine my
whole life
has changed we bought it yeah uh ally
and jojo
no no no no yeah you're thinking a
different one so what happened
uh so you were absolutely
uh that song started playing i was like
oh [ __ ] yeah
yeah you're all dressed up i had to tie
on and [ __ ]
all uncomfortable in khakis bro so i
walked up to her i was like hey
uh you know you want to dance you know
and she was like
oh my feet hurt i was like oh okay cool
cool cool cool
same song is playing she's dancing with
another [ __ ] dude
ah bruh bro is this your friend now
is she my friend now yeah no no no this
is a different this is a girl that
crumpled up the paper
damn you stayed on it though i stayed on
are you hammered at this party
uh no after oh yeah
chill no hammered hey hey you like
genuine [ __ ] yeah
girl [ __ ] we're all drinking right
now
like you weren't drinking i was not
drinking i didn't drink until after
college
you're high in 21. you haven't drink
until after high school
you ought to grow up i don't grow up in
mesa that's why it makes it a little
different yeah
when did you have your first drink he's
never had a drink never had a drink oh
yeah he still has it don't drink a smoke
i respect that
but see but like dude were you asking
out girls like that like were you just
like hey will you be my girlfriend oh
yeah
you see you did the what yeah shoot her
shoot man shooters let you back then
yeah shoot her shoot shoot a shirt with
with
nerf guns you know back then i was shoot
how were you when you got your first
kiss though oh [ __ ] i was 16.
you're 16. that's good it's late in the
game
i mean yeah what hey [ __ ] off guys
spells i had my first kid kiss at 27.
no one can relate to it no first kiss at
26
no one held hands with a girl first time
at 29
i had my first kiss in sixth grade it
was this mix girl she was so
bad and she was she was aggressive i
remember she kissed me in front of all
my homies oh she grabbed you
yeah like just she had these big lips
she was mixed
fine as [ __ ] there you go we were both
in sixth grade chill
so then i remember she kissed me in
front of my friends after some art class
and then i remember my friend cameron
wilson pulled my pants down from
everybody while you were getting
while you were making out yeah hey it
was so embarrassing let that thing pop
out
man that's the thing i hate it on you
cameron i got a big one what a hater
though
yeah what a hair i wrote a lover well
how old were you i wrote a love letter
in sixth grade until my crush she was in
eighth grade and i wrote like the other
oh you always liked alderweireld
i always liked older women yeah and all
right like this is like usher nice and
slow was popping so i just wrote
the whole third verse like you know they
call me m-a-l-i-k-b-a-z-i-l-l-e
and i wrote all that and i put in a
locker and it was so many typos
in that letter
[Laughter]
did you get my letter and she was like
yeah were y'all were y'all bad students
like me
no no no i was just i was trying to go
to university of colorado so i i got
good grades
i had to give you guys
no i got like good grades i was just
when i was young
i was out of control like in seventh
grade like i got into like
three none of them were my fault i'll
admit that book i was like
like i was having eraser fights like
with my friends like
in the middle of class we just start
humming [ __ ] at each other the youngest
yeah yeah like i was getting like i got
into a couple
fights in seventh grade but like i
wasn't like like me and my friends like
it was the same friend group since like
second grade so we were just very small
a town very small school
we were just out of control you're
trying to swing at your teachers
no i didn't know any of y'all had a fool
fight
none of you yeah okay i never have a
food fight i'm not correct
chin uh you had your first girlfriend
win
i'm like chapelle my first girlfriend
probably
20 no 23 24. oh
late yeah even when you but
before then weren't you like trying to
dance and sing and [ __ ]
no so i'm the only reason i had
girlfriends because they
did the move because i was so i was
super super shy they had to be imagining
yeah yeah was you bigger at the time
oh no so when i was in my twenties or
you know mid
early you lost that yeah yeah wait you
were
bigger 300 pounds
the chin got shredded he just stopped
yeah he got shredded
it's one of my favorite pictures on
earth
and would you have your first boyfriend
kat my first
boyfriend was in seventh grade
it's about normal yeah and then i got a
boyfriend in high school and like kept
him forever
yes you did kept him
for way too long i appreciate that i've
had my first girlfriend now because
yeah i was just too crazy a little more
mature now yeah a lot a lot more mature
you know what i mean you guys can be
talking i'll look for so no wait no one
tried to swing at a teacher
no dude we don't play that [ __ ] doug
y'all don't play that [ __ ] i
i mean i went playing hey dope ass
teacher stuff we can't have my teachers
are fine
i asked out my teacher one time that the
best
that's your teacher out yeah she was bad
as hell bro grade
uh sixth grade you had a crush on your
teacher yeah i
i had a crush on my fourth grade teacher
i was like ah there's no christian look
at this
that was chin god damn thank you
proud of you now but damn are those
those are the overalls you're wearing
no no it was a those that's not overall
it's like that's what jingles
oh god i got it she looks so scared
i'm gonna have to bleep her not bleep
her this is from
dallas in dallas no this is here in
orange county oh in orange county it's
sadie hawkins once again
the girl had that yeah the girl has that
yeah i remember sadie hawkins
yeah mm-hmm i went to a couple dances i
got down
it's just this picture so crazy because
i remember it looks like i'm a
ventriloquist
i'm not even kidding like i'm like a
puppet
do you have a are you are you single now
christian yeah
i i just never really i had a girlfriend
like when i was younger i just
like once i got to high school i did not
want to deal with it i didn't have the
time i played sports i like
school work i just did not want to put
up yeah what about now though
right now nah you know those girls that
don't have [ __ ]
yeah not where i went not where i went
you're fine
i don't find a one for like a little bit
but i
never would put a label on it ever i
just never wanted to be like tied it was
a situation [ __ ]
yeah like i like i'd like hang around
with her and like have
like fun like we'd hang out for a little
bit and then like
i just get bored with it have you hung
out with anyone recently
uh yeah when i was back in uh home in
rhode island for a little bit about here
though
on just got here like uh yeah no not
like
the girls out here are you on the apps
and stuff
oh yeah yeah some are coming up bro
yeah come on someone's coming up we
gotta set you up now there's actually a
girl
from back home that's actually moving
out so i'm gonna like set that up
i'm gonna help to use us yeah
there you go boy had a plan all along i
know right yeah
i like that christmas big plans i see
you christian why wait so like
she's not superficial like i care about
who you are money-wise
she's legit it was crazy i got a text
last night from
uh my friend who was visiting like my
oldest brother's friend like went to
middle school with this kid he who lives
out here now
his sister was out here recently on her
flight back to boston
she was talking about how she was moving
out here
and there was this girl from where the
town i'm from started to talk to her
i got a dm from the uh from my friend's
sister saying
yeah i just met your friend i'm not
going to say your name but
so long story short i this doesn't
really make any sense i know it's very
long weekend
i'm sorry i'm not trying to actually
whenever someone says
so but i'm locked in my friend met
a girl i grew up with on a plane yeah
and from middle school from middle
school and
found out that she's moving out and then
you're yeah you're gonna help her
yeah she's like yeah i'm nervous i know
that story made no sense i'm sorry who
got shot
but she was telling me she's like yeah
i'm nervous to moving out like i don't
know anyone said no don't worry
i'm out here now i'll take care of y'all
make sure you get situated
i'll show you around don't worry you
like john b bro that's what you like
who oh yeah yeah you smooth they don't
know old school um you got to be careful
with these girls out here though
just in case you're telling me no i was
single bro last year the quarantine
like i'm talking about like february
march it's how crazy these girls was
like
i was going little players stuff like
that i thought i was the man
i told this girl like yo man i was a
little bit and i told the girl like yo
put your
you know put your number in my phone i'm
chopping it up with her all that she's
like alright cool
call me right i walk off she even get up
put her number in the phone
she cashed out myself a hundred dollars
yes that's what she is that's that's
scary
women i'll do they do that out here bro
be careful
yeah and why
[Applause]
did you open like the contact no so so
listen
no way after because you're like ooh
because she's like can't you avoid it or
something because she actually just put
her
contact info in there yes exactly i put
all i was on there with representatives
it's probably too late
someone the email pops up so i didn't
notice until i'm like yo
i called you but i'm like bro yeah i
remember you telling me this yeah yeah
so be careful yeah
it's a new scam going on out here as
well though what
bro you got to talk to justin about it
but i don't put my man business out
there but yeah what happened
oh come on man come on man yeah you
can't do that you know what it is
you don't have to make it personal about
justin but we'll know it's him
right yeah
just tell us the scam though is
christian's single and
oh yeah but he has a girl coming out
here tonight
[Music]
we don't believe it too i was a friend
no friend
i mean that that was that was more like
that cash out i'm just be aware of that
but i i mean i've never i mean i've
gotten numbers i've never
that has that happened to me but oh what
yeah boy this is their damn dog
yeah we want to know the scam yeah i i
it's too
i don't know my scam and i want it now
just give us the general idea
the general idea is like uh you know
justin like he's down 200 dollars
because this girl but i let i
i can't remember
it's kind of like it's not it's more
like a paypal all right because he's
selling merch
right and uh oh can i put his business
out like that no it's too close he had
to tell a story
yeah but yeah he down 200 and they do
that do you think it's this
camera did he just get hustled but on
these apps though cause you on these
apps right because he justin's on all of
them on paypal as in
the dating apps they're dating there's a
paypal dating app
i guess i don't know no it's not paypal
is just
there's no dating app that's linked to a
thing i think justin was trying to pay
for something
yeah and then god there's nothing that's
like a dating site because like grindr
and tinder and all that and bumblebee
or j-date or farmers only or black
there's no
there's just just black there's no money
involved
in exchange so
i mean i have like match with like i
match with a girl on tinder like we were
supposed to go out to dinner and
everything she's like
yeah i need gas money so can you venmo
me twenty-five dollars no no no no
but you know that no like was that like
the situation no no
no i don't can speak for my situation
that girl can cash out myself a hundred
dollars i never no
no no i meant with justin oh justin i
don't know yeah but
that that cash out thing that was a
thing that was going around i was going
around like during quarantine like
and it was like it was trending on
twitter i was like yeah i got got
yeah and they quit giving girls your
phone though yeah yeah i'd be like no
i got this oh you want to type it in
i'll type in i'm not giving them my
phone [ __ ] you
oh but i'm saying you already have it
let's say you have your phone you
already have the contacts and the
numbers like that
and then she types no no just tell me
your [ __ ] number
she was but i don't let her once she
puts in that's it i don't like like i
make sure to watch her put it in yeah
but i thought i wouldn't give her my
phone though but we're parallel to each
other
to give someone your phone no if you you
rapping right like yeah i'm not listen
put your number
and i know i don't know what's your
number girl and then i can do it well i
know that because i i don't have
that you know i don't i can i'm not
peanut butter falcon i can do it myself
what is that here yeah i get what
malatin like it's it's just mostly like
like you pull up the context like you're
vibing with the girl you pull up the
concert gear and how desperate you have
to be
to go through my app right because you
know i'm chopping up with it i was like
it's easy to search because they just
like yeah yeah and there's like cash
type move girl so here's another thing
she clearly wasn't
she didn't like you clearly there wasn't
a vibe if she had the intent of getting
money from you yeah
different than strippers you thought a
stripper liked you exactly
and we always money on strippers yeah
when you guys are like man cinnamon
actually she's talking about leaving man
i'm going to give her some money so she
can get out of here
man she's there for the baby
girls yeah they get you too hoarders
they get them big ass tips
hooters yeah dude i enjoy hooters wings
they are good
anything else something else on the menu
you don't need don't touch any other
yeah
no in long beach by the racetrack
it's good by the restoration hardware um
the girls are ridiculous because you're
not now hooters
because everyone's so woke you know
hooters can't hire girls just based off
their big titties
yeah that was the thing for a while
though there was a lawsuit about that
really
when hooters started popping off there
was a lawsuit where a girl said she
wasn't hired because she did
because she didn't have big boobs did
they say that to her though
uh that was one of those like
prerequisites at that time
with tutors yeah it's like me suing the
nfl
not running fast enough they're like you
gotta run fast dude
in the nfl i think she won based off of
like some sort of
bias to her and so it became policy with
hooters where
they couldn't deny someone a job because
you didn't have big boobs but what you
would have to do is part of your uniform
you'd wear multiple bras to push it up
even more
so some girls would walk around with
like three three bras and then
victoria's secret came out with that bra
that did
uh two cup sizes up that's great so
girls would do that yeah it's funny and
it just pushes it just pushes the
the skin up i guess it's basically
like imagine like your hands and you're
just like pushing the buttons
we should get your job at hooters being
a waitress [ __ ] hooters
you know you i'll work you ever been a
tilted kilt
i don't think we have a lot of them out
here there's some out here i've heard
that but now the thing
uh that kind of overrides hooters is
twin peaks oh twin peaks twin peaks has
some
back home also references the big
titties
they have a better one in atlanta and in
houston twin peaks
but it's a twin peaks yeah for sure i
used to talk to this girl twin peaks
yeah yeah back home in arizona we have
this thing called bikini beans
oh yeah where they're in the bikini oh i
think there's one in orange county
oh yeah we launched we were gonna launch
oh yeah
the coffee shop that is dark roast and a
dick suck what
is there one uh is there out here here
twin peaks
i think they're out here like hell
lately i don't know yeah because i
would imagine like orange county or
orange county for sure orange county i
feel
like vietnamese coffee shops kind of
have a monopoly on
sacramento phoenix there's one in denver
yeah go to one in atlanta
they have one in atlanta arizona talk to
the girl yeah
we got them in arizona oh they have a
roadhouse out here
the owner of roadhouse commit suicide
what's roadhouse rollhouses
oh yeah
oh really why pandemic [ __ ]
oh it's recent [ __ ] yeah super recent
because yeah something like guy look at
him
that's the guy you would expect to own
texas roadhouse
damn severe tinnitus with side effects
tinnitus yeah you were sick of dealing
with like he was always yeah
you know tyus is a freaking it sucks
especially if you're because most
audio guys all the time right yeah but
then if you mention it
then you start hearing it again but if
you don't talk about it for a while it
kind of goes away
uh how do you kill himself there's
there's stuff but i don't think once
once you have it you're gonna always
have it so this can sound like a jet
engine roaring inside your ear it's just
24
7. yeah no there's no cure for it not
that i know of
how how did he kill him so
i made that up i have no clue oh
they don't tell the 537 texas roadhouse
those things were lit
too many [ __ ] they had the best the
peanuts all over the floor and [ __ ] yeah
i love that [ __ ]
just throw [ __ ] on the floor yeah they
had a good uh
chicken fried steak they have good steak
yeah and then the rolls the rolls were
lit as [ __ ] rolls are the ones yeah i
know what you're talking about
we like carbs yeah we can't have a
minute remember red lobster rolls
oh those are still i don't
uh grocery stores you could get at
target ralph's oh really yeah
yeah i can't eat red lobster though dawg
yeah i just get the rose yeah yeah you
get those you can get full off the roads
crab rolls or rolls like a cheddar roll
they're gonna have some crab but i might
doubt
if they sprinkle some of them i knew
that's gonna happen you know what i'm
saying yeah
i thought do you like those places where
you eat the
grabs all messy and [ __ ] uh you talking
about boiling crap like falling
right real sweet gloves it's a lot of
work it looks like so much more
a lot of work you got to wear gloves
when you eat though yeah oh
oh because just so like it doesn't like
contaminate your hands up and then your
hands
they get all dry you smell like garlic
for the rest of the day
every time it's disgusting what's
crustaceans seafood
oh crustacean's good yeah and it's way
better
seafood is dope i remember in the south
they have these like boiling crabs where
they just throw like all these
dumplings they give one little ass corn
on the cob right here
is
no it's not that
it's their my mouth is watering it's
their i know this [ __ ] looks so good i
wish i could
oh it's almost like their popcorn shrimp
right it's breaded and then deep fried
uh it's it's deep fried but then they
just douse it with their sauce and
butter and there's rice in it you mix it
all up it's [ __ ] great
hey i think i'm good with uh avocado now
you powered through it yeah power
through it oh you can eat
yeah i was just doing it little by
little very very little
yeah taking baby steps congratulations
baby step now you can have avocado toast
like everyone else i don't think i want
that yeah do i love avocado toast
that's good because i went to chipotle
and i like i just yeah i saw you get the
sides
aside and then i just like you know
little by little so i think i'm
yeah come on now all right give some
credits doug sure do you want to do
the rating segment oh i forgot let's do
that
a lot of people have been like asking
where it's been oh okay it's once a week
man did we not do it last week
no we didn't yeah we didn't we didn't
this episode of fighter and the kids is
brought to you by
keeps that means keeps the hair that you
have y'all more than 50 million
dudes in the united states suffer from
male pattern baldness yep they go
involved man
and there are only two fda approved
medications that can prevent hair loss
and keeps offers both keeps offers a
simple stress-free way to keep your hair
convenient virtual doctors hit you up
man and they give you medications
delivered straight to your door every
three months
so you never have to leave your crib and
you can grow them long locks
low cost treatments just start at ten
dollars per month and keeps offers
generic versions comes up a little
discrete package
nobody has to know that you're growing
these logs you're doing it through keeps
all right
prevention is key treatments can take
four to six months see results so act
fast all right if you're ready to take
action prevent hair loss go to k-e-e-p-s
dot com slash fighter to receive your
first month of treatment
free that's keeps.com fighter to get
your first month free
k-e-e-p-s dot com fighter man
think about all the quarantine purchase
you made all that pizza
all those movies all the subscriptions
all the
shorts or whatever the hell you're
buying man then there's one
of your biggest purchase of the year was
insurance americans overspend on car and
home insurance by billions every year
but
but billions y'all not millions we're
talking billions
that's money that could have been spent
on more retail therapy
or shoes whatever you're into or pizza
that's where the zebra can help you the
zebra's nation's leading insurance
comparison site
for car and home insurance in minutes
you can compare policies from every
major provider for free all
on one independent marketplace after a
few quick questions
the zebra pairs people with the right
insurance company for them helping
everyone save time and money
buy online or over the phone with one of
their licensed insurance agents
all right make insurance your smartest
purchase yet
visit the zebra.com fighter that's
t h e z e b r a dot com slash fighter
the zebra dot com slash fighter
and john so rate my state this is and
johnny's five seven hundred six pounds i
love that he gave his height and weight
reserve firefighter emt orange county
five orange county five
i thought he was for sure jersey sure oh
oh no you when you put the kids in
you get a bonus point come on man the
kid he's a firefighter firefighter
firefighter
he's a reserve fighter fighter what does
that mean emt that
means he's on the bench so if there's a
fighter he's like the last one
the slide down the pole he's not even on
the pole
i think he's at home like hey dog we
need your help
don't toss your [ __ ] off man it's [ __ ]
too big though
have you seen only the brave no
about the uh california fires oh yeah i
think yeah that huge like
those are he's the guy who they call up
when there's that those massive forest
fires yeah wild cards
yeah so he's not i don't think he's
working i think he's an emt
okay orange county five guy dude
firefighter and emt
wait so if you're a reserve that you
have to say that on your pouch like
i'm a reserve yeah i don't say a pouch
though so he thinks he's an orange
he's saying he's an orange county five i
get higher than a five i get them higher
than five
i'm a seven what are you giving i would
give him an orange county a
i'd give him six in orange county yeah
i'm gonna give him a six he looks like a
seven there
yeah yeah but it almost looks like a
different guy that's that's the best
picture of him well
you're gonna send your best and he has
that nice little salmon dinner waiting
for him i like that yeah i see that
yeah oh yeah yeah
and he give us a side picture he's small
though yeah five seven five seven yeah
it's small
hey we can't knock people for that
height small oh yeah we do we got a duck
people like we gotta do people like
small guys for the height
well no some people like that there's a
there's a market for that like a
christian
yeah you're right i actually like short
guys better i'm gonna get my i'm gonna
give them a seven
how tall stevie uh like five seven five
eight yeah i'd say five short yeah but
yeah he's short
she said i say i think most girls prefer
taller guys though
yeah yeah recently it's been like uh
girls who are even my one a guy who's
like six one and up yeah by recently you
mean
for all like 5 10 and up not necessarily
like 6-1
for a while there were girls who were
just like i will only date a guy if he's
above
six feet taller before like if you're 5
10 5 11 like you can kind of play with
the numbers yeah i don't think that yeah
maybe
but i think for all of six as long as
mankind's been around they like the
bigger dude
if you go on any dating app like if
you're swiping swiping
there will be like at least seven out of
the ten girls like say you swipe
ten times six seven out of ten will be
like oh don't message me unless you're
six feet tall
but that's the stance i don't even i
don't even i don't even try it just
swipe left i'm like not even
not even worth it they right they write
that yeah of course is there is
not a dating site for short people i
wish i'd be [ __ ] killing them
what's [ __ ] up is if i put in my bio
don't swipe right unless you're under
like 1 30. you're get canceled yeah yeah
yeah that's fine yeah it's the double
standard my man
there has to be a shortcut yes
there's hope for me now is short
is he he's from five eight damn small
short kings have always walked them up
yes
i'm about to download this so it's just
an actual short king dating yeah short
king dating it's a sight
oh it's a sight i don't want to do those
sights hey you better get on there you
better stop playing stop playing bro
what are they doing you first
updated the site hold on let me see this
tweet look it says
it says i'm [ __ ] tired of short use
as an insult short gave you donald
glover
short gave you tom holland short gave
you daniel kaluya
short gave you bruno [ __ ] marsh short
kings are the
enemy of body negativity and i'll be
forever proud to defend them
damn right yeah i'll defend kevin hart
kevin hart short
super short now do you want me to go to
the list of successful tall people
oh don't do it like i mean should we do
that we'll have that at that time
well that kind of time like i mean hey
don't get me wrong though there is a lot
of successful short people tom cruise
uh tom cruise yeah mark wahlberg
like i just said kevin hart don cheadle
i guess there's
but not even like in acting they're you
generally pretty small
what do you mean actors no they're not
like huge
what is do you get on
wow christian get on this girl oh
christian and dude and you're going on
these tiny dates
these tiny
sure must be a short king 5 8 or shorter
or short king lover
and dude and they're lgbtq friendly
oh i like that you never know man yeah
look at that little short guy five three
guys look at gus look at bailey dude a
first responder
yeah don't have your mask on though phil
yeah chill phil yeah
damn it's honestly absolutely she's five
seconds not on the app store
not yet oh oh get early actually
that's just probably just started oh
[ __ ] sign up for our beta and get free
premium for one year
but after dude short king
yeah you might just thrive oh hell dude
i'm two inches taller than god yeah
dude now i wonder if it's gonna be
regular-sized girls or if it's tiny
girls too on there
they showed a five ten girls five ten
she told me so this is just girls that
are into short games
some really tall like short guys yeah
no like one so i did like hang out with
a girl who was like
5 10 and like when i realized i didn't
like
tall girls it was when i like her and i
went to kiss her she had to like
bend down or like like like squats
i was like yeah she was like sitting
like on the armrest like out like to get
head left with me i was like standing on
my tippy toes i got it this ain't for me
so your ideal girls five two five three
oh yeah i'd go same height maybe like
even an inch or two taller
just like how tall are you five five so
if we got like a five there's a lot of
baddie five three five two
yeah which what an ethnicity are we
talking here white
no what's your name
if you don't want to deal with all the
drama though you might want to go with
the basic white
house i'm just basic white could be
drama hell yeah they're just someone i
like like i like
asian uh latino or black guy
too like i just like anything that has
like a little feistiness in it yeah
you're like
white girls yeah you're like you like
short black girls huh
oh yeah yeah with like a blood ass
yeah dude let's get on short kings only
oh
i got what if there's a short black
kings only
wait what wait wait why are you no
he could be on there because he likes
black oh god he likes short black queens
yeah yeah short black queens
okay shorty queens i'll hook you up with
my home girl she black short
nah man don't list them out stay on the
app
this girl is going to steal your [ __ ]
money apparently
i know this girl this girl no i don't
trust her man
um oh so back to him yeah i give him i
give him a six i'll give him five
you know what i'll give i'm with
chappelle i'll give him a seven just
because he's a firefighter and he's the
dad
and that kid's cute as [ __ ] 6.5 now he's
a five in every picture but the one here
is a seven
he got good teeth with a nice salmon
dinner next to him he's got good teeth
hell yeah shout out to anjon yeah
don't worry it looks like he very and
is he italian or indian indian
oh yeah dude and john's not italian cat
angel in that photo he looks a little
italian to me it's just i see what
you're saying
it's just because he's tan with brown
eyes yeah he's definitely racist
where's defense of that i'm tan with
brown eyes
some drama going on i'm i'm tanned with
brown eyes
you're not tan i want to say tan your
evidence what else you got jen
oh chad father of three at 25 wow
wow worker hashtag good guy 25 ontario
canada
father of three canada has some dimeys
guys why does it look so different yeah
well he's got
in his submission he did say uh you
mentioned that his girl was on and he
told
he said he wanted to say tell brennan to
chill talk
about my girls maple leaf hitters
i did call her that's also what you
sign up for yeah when you submit your
wife on this
his wife is a diamond with those
piercing blue eyes what do we give his
cute couple he gives girls i think i
gave her yeah we gave her a pretty high
rating
uh yeah remember she had them big maple
leaf titties
um i would definitely say chad shaved
the mustache if you want to get rid of
that mustache
and get a beer he's tatted up
he's a child youth worker father three
also
fought the bow tie kind his friend is
seven his friend is a one
um [ __ ] that's great i would give him a
picture
what his friend is the one although
looks very friendly in life of the party
but still in one
um i give chad a god i can't have some
dimes
i give chad a five give him five even
though he's a child youth
ontario five or else actually the
mustache i'll drop him down to six
i give him ontario five okay because all
right so we're doing ontario uh i'll
give about yeah i'm with brynn i'll give
him a five give her five
so what does ellie b rating be oh how
dare you go there yeah come on
l.a dude you're singing why you asked
that question
that's what we have this is
there's some there's so many failed
actors and comics out here man that's
true
and they're good looking he's an la3 but
he's a
canada five cat what do you give him
you're the
female here for godzilla i have never
been to canada so i
can't assess what his ontario they're
popular
vancouver toronto montreal because i
know girls in canada tend to be hot as
[ __ ]
guys there's a lot of yeah hot guys
great canada
i don't think bieber is the most
attractive man oh wow really i think
he's attractive
i don't know he's short white no
i like from canada i either like really
nerdy asian guys or
guys that look like paul walker those
are like my two people
paul walker before or after paul walker
whenever i love him so like
after the accident yeah sure
chris dark whoa he was going dark yeah
because i was trying to figure out when
he was trying to we're trying to make
you a short king
you're [ __ ] yourself
as we speak but i think he's like
this dude ella chris how do you know
orlando florida six do you know him
he dm dm but but you don't know him no
no
okay okay well uh he's 26 who has some
style those dunks are flying jeans will
fly look at the
outfit that that that
the haircut that that nixon watch not
fly uh orlando florida six so he's six
foot 175 that means he's bodied up
amateur fighter
okay podcaster good for you tsa agent
come on man
come on man we gotta go through orlando
so i'm gonna choose my words wise
he got hookups on buddy passes uh
i'm gonna go eight yeah i was gonna say
eight i'm gonna go eight orlando eight
yeah i'll give him orlando eight yeah
yeah i give him a hard mickey mouse
eight
yeah that outfit there's pretty fly what
do you give him cat
do you like black guys that all cat yes
i do very specific ones though
like i think idris elba is fine as [ __ ]
huh let's say
darker ones yeah him uh i think trey
songz is fine i think michael b jordan
is very handsome
um so there's one more uh his name
oh romeo miller is fine there's uh rome
flynn masterpiece
from uh how to get away with murder he's
not he's not black
he's mixed yeah how to get away with
murder yeah wrong flynn
rome flynn is a beautiful [ __ ] he's
not but he's i think he's like cute yeah
he's not
full uh i think it's because he looks
filipino that's why i think he's a mixed
oh he's
definitely good looking yeah he's fine
yeah it was
fun yeah it's fine
all right let's go back to homeboy that
guy is fine as [ __ ]
but that's also what's rolling around
l.a chris right yeah
that's why i said orlando earlier
orlando eight l.a orlando eight
yeah i got six for la that's fair
yeah i give you six he's around here but
his passion
fits out here really well wait hold on
time out you give him a five and the six
you give justin to la three
what oh justin's teeth fixed so what is
he now
i didn't give justin the three you keep
saying that what no i think brendan gave
him a three yeah
i'm the only one with three oh what what
did you give him kat uh i think even
like a four
no one was i don't think it went higher
nobody i said five to six i said four
point five
yeah that would be higher did i say
three four
four three yeah you didn't say higher
than the five or six i was
not see but but i know just giving them
a three uh you give them a three bucks
close friend yeah which is fine no no
yeah you gave her three because you said
chin was higher
but uh justin got his teeth oh justin is
six yeah just in a six now he has teeth
fixed
all right that gives you crazy points
crazy crazy ooh heather
cam listen women you don't have to give
your height and weight we're not trying
to
get in trouble here uh port arthur texas
i have no clue where that's at i've been
all over texas i have a texas tattoo
uh 5'4 170 oh you thick thick uh
finance major works for motiva 24.
she's on the left there she that's your
sister on the right i assume
she looks she's bigger than five four
like she looks tall
until your point puerto rico is close to
dallas it's like that's what i was gonna
say is this is dallas
this is the hood cover shout out to
porto i got some friends out there
is it like opalaca it's kind of like
that is it hoodie out there
is it it's like a gas heather 24 hour
she looks nice
she looks real friendly finance major
smart yeah
texas so she's a southern bell she
didn't take care of you try to cook you
some peach cobbler
just for the [ __ ] of it dude peach
cobbling a dick sock
anyone else anyone i'm with that buddy
yeah right
that's the south dude that's what they
do yeah i mean i was just i don't know
if she's in it i'm just saying that's
the thing go back to that
okay damn that's her mom clearly yeah
okay that might be her friend oh you're
about to say a friend i mean
you got that you got that older friend
though your friend has old face
uh so heather's 24.
5'4 170. i like how you want to roast
everyone who isn't in the competition
hold on hold on you think they're the
same age
no they're not they might be though they
might are they so let's
let's assume that the heather's 24.
let's assume
you're probably 20. let's call her let's
call her friend diane on the left
okay so let's say she's 24. she's 24
yeah she if she's 24 she'll have old
face
old face oh face god damn so you mean
tell me there's nothing
but there's nothing wrong with that look
at my face
i mean you don't have old faces that was
the worst comparison right yeah
enough about her older friend let's talk
about heather
all right i give heather a seven i was
gonna say seven seven i was gonna say
seven points because she
because she she also a good thick fake
yeah
texas seven or poor arthur said no port
arthur now listen i've been a port
arthur it's
nothing out there so we're gonna do
texas all right she's to point out that
she's a 12.
okay oh but texas in general this is in
general i say 7.6 she looks so
friendly i give her seven seven and a
half all right
same i'm saying normal with that five
four 170 girls
all i can say is wait till the next
person a word
all right veronica veronica all right
what veronica talking about oh i know oh
i know veronica you know her too you
know veronica
oh wait did she submit herself for king
this
no that's a different girl right listen
let's just pretend
everyone's trying to figure out how they
know her uh bernard is 25
shout out to math bakersfield california
510
170 mother of two staying active
shooting hoops
jogging drives the hemi dodge rt charger
i fell in love when i saw her she she's
definitely a la
like what are we are we doing l.a or
bakersfield
bakersfield she's a 12. no let's do this
let's do bakersfield she's a 15. yeah
she's 15.
she's a la 9. she's up there she's nine
nine yeah like nine and a half
i just don't give out tens around here
but she's a nine she's as close we've
come to ten correct
and she's a mom as a mother of two
clearly latin as well what you want to
play for full set of lips as well i'll
play for your heart dog
she's not what do you give her chin why
are you looking at me
because i like your face staring at the
camera i will say this she's definitely
hot right
oh god
because her face looks like there's so
much work done so that's her lip maybe
her lips are
probably her guys i think it's just her
lips maybe good eyelashes but something
for whatever reason when i see something
that doesn't look real
it kind of knocks it down a little bit
do you think that's the way that she
does her makeup
maybe that too but her tits look great i
like her tits i know they're not real
oh god those are like your dad's saying
tits huh
her breasts look [ __ ] fantastic
she looks great right here she's super
batty she can hold bro she's the highest
ranking i'll say that
i'll say nine you say nine championships
you still get right feels peer pressure
to say that but you'd probably give her
seven
if we're off here if you're off here
i'll give her eight yeah there you go
you know you might you know you pretty
well
yeah i give her a nine and a half but if
you see her if you still play basketball
would you give her a higher grade if she
looks more real
yeah she like yeah no i'm talking about
playing basketball and she can get down
if she sends you her best video would
you to give her a like
oh i would love to see a video about
that yeah a video
i would i would d the [ __ ] out of her i
would block every one of her shots
i don't care but i don't probably shoot
over you bro not a chance she is 510
though
yeah that's what i'm saying and i'm 6'4
and i'd block the [ __ ] out of her
all right but she's smoking man there's
that right yeah smoking
shut up veronica highest highest ranking
we've had for sure yeah
you take the rate my state crown right
now girl yeah
all right that's all the that's what we
got for this one good job christian
yeah hell yeah okay so
caitlyn jenner is gonna run for governor
of california
and arnold schwarzenegger came out and
said that he thinks she has a really
good chance of winning against gavin
yeah you have the hard hat yeah did you
yeah
no you said it right don't let them feel
it's just that
we'll take it like that's to be racist
no good
that gots to
tiptoe around this yeah we can just call
him arnold
i just call him arnold so i don't get it
i don't know
okay so uh our former governor uh the
terminator
came out and said that he thinks that
caitlyn jenner would do really well
against uh gavin newsom during the
recall
here's the thing about this and listen
no one hates newsome more than me
there's probably a few people out there
that do uh and hates a strong word i
just dislike him
he's corrupt as [ __ ] but um and he's
dealt with the the
handling of this pandemic probably the
worst out of anyone besides the new york
governor
but the thing about the recall is it's
gonna
it's gonna it's gonna take forever
mm-hmm like the white house i'm just
happy
god knows by the time it happens i think
they're saying things will start popping
like november really so
it's almost a waste of time and then
there's really no like
caitlyn jenner doesn't really know
politics he's not like a strong famous
candidate like arnold schwarzenegger
so by the time this goes around
everything's gonna be open school's
gonna be open
stores gonna be open so they're people
just gonna forget about it do you think
it all blows over as soon as 100
as soon as we open up no one's gonna
give a [ __ ] about new summer this recall
or anything
but the what the recall does help is but
what's interesting is before this
pandemic newsome was killing it
california's like doing the best it's
ever done you know with money and the
infrastructure and everything he was
crushing it
the pandemic hit and he just [ __ ] his
pants and locked this down and [ __ ]
every small business over yeah in
schools and suicides up in gun violence
anyways
but when things open up no one's going
to care mm-hmm yeah
and then caitlyn jenner's not a strong
enough candidate to do anything like
click on calendar i would vote for
kaitlyn jennifer newsom we're not going
to have to it's by the time everything
opens up this can be no it's good we
have bigger problems
yeah alrighty
okay so justin bieber is being accused
of cultural appropriation again because
recently he showed a photo on instagram
of his new care which is him in the
process of getting dreadlocks
who's accusing him uh the internet
they don't count yeah they don't care
yeah yeah i mean it's just
[ __ ] so now that really ruins your
day
that now hold on now now no one can have
uh dreads you can only have dreads if
you're black that's the rule
well twitter's rules yeah i'm sure
justin didn't give a [ __ ]
yeah hope he's not paying attention yeah
i wouldn't does this offend you malek
no i'm looking at that's not really
dress that's not a lot he's in the
process he's
always clearly in the process there's
definitely some wax in there okay
no okay i'm more worried about his
pearls whatever um
but what let me ask you this question
what
how did you get to that point where you
want to change up your look and get
dreads and then you know that he did it
once in i think 2016. he did it for a
short amount of time
he never got to a point where it
actually became locks
he just kind of started the process but
why do they want to get locked
though i'm just but why not like what if
white people when a black person grows
their hair i'll go hey you're
you're taking from our culture you're
growing the hair out we have long hair
yeah
we don't give a [ __ ] yeah no no i'm just
saying why
and also dude you're just like why does
he want to do it yeah
but why not [ __ ] yeah he can do it my
other thing is
isn't there bigger issues and fish to
fry than
why do i want to care about this is it
black culture saying that oh yeah uh
well white people
aren't upset bro you'd be surprised
you'd be surprised
you're right the wolf left i think cares
more about this
than the black community yeah because
like because the black community has
real problems
and they're like dude we're more worried
about getting shot in the [ __ ]
street and justin bieber growing [ __ ]
dreads yeah
i don't even i don't even notice that i
know i didn't even if i saw that picture
i'm like
how long ago was it did he post this
like it did it goes two days two days
ago yeah i
give two shits oh no those are corners
if you look at the comments it's
i don't see not one black no it's just
social media trying like they gotta find
something to be upset about yeah
something on like yeah
you better come out with a [ __ ]
reggae album i'll tell you that much
that'd be like that'll be hard
it better be hard as [ __ ] i'm ready for
it justin well he did that one with him
bring chet hanks on because he can speak
that patois
my boy summer's a slap boomba clock
whatever he's [ __ ]
like he said yeah you know
you got you follow me yeah but yeah not
okay i'm not gonna i didn't see any of
this i had dreadlocks
when i was in i think in high school
yeah because i just
i gotta go dig deep cause before that
was it because of corn
because you're a fan of corn i loved it
it just looked cool to me so i wanted to
get it yeah well my thing is where does
the culture appropriation
stop like these jordans this is this you
don't say another one
is this culture appropriation if i buy
jordans it's
just weird it's like at what point do
you guys stop i think and literally
start fighting a real fight like this
ain't it man
it just continued to move the goal post
do you remember when jeremy lin did his
hair
yeah yeah another basketball player he
did sort of like uh
he did straight up yeah i shaved
nba player that called him out for
dreads jeremy lin then
said well why do you have a chinese
tattoo on you yeah totally got him down
you're talking about you talking about
kenyan martin
martin just like yeah he's a enforcer
i don't know yeah i don't know that's
not a fighter
i would care to fight no okay
okay so a jogger in germany was running
through the woods when he saw a very
disheveled looking backpack
and he got worried because this part of
germany there was a battle and a lot of
times there were like leftover grenades
left over guns and stuff like that so he
thought that there was a
grenade or some sort of explosive in
this backpack he called police
police officers and basically their
equivalent of
bomb control came out check the backpack
and they realized that they found
other things next to what looked like a
grenade like a usb
cord some lube condoms and they found
out that the grenade
that was spawned is actually a sex toy a
pr probably a butt plug right grenade
i don't know if it was a bump like they
don't go to somebody's butt
they don't go into it but they say it's
a toy
what it's a toy that vibrated yeah
that's going some man's butt
that's some german dude putting grenades
on his mind
you know [ __ ] grenade [ __ ] that's
what the lube is for
they're actually not that big have you
ever seen a real grenade they're not
like huge
put in an [ __ ]
i've also seen some porn words like how
do they do this and they figure it out
do you remember the one mike catherine
showed all of us the video of the two
guys
oh yeah oh my god and i've also seen
some big dicks going butts too
i'm not going to lie i saw a video in
high school um
yeah it's a little terrifying i'm not
gonna lie i saw a video in high school
of this guy
putting his entire head inside of a girl
like oh the ball had to do yeah you
don't talk about yeah yeah i know
it was terrifying i mean listen i've
seen two large
dick black men put both their wieners in
a girl's butt oh
it's called a double dp give it up dog i
hate you but damn
yeah so like a grenade oh no i can't do
nothing like that i know like with the
homie like right so how big
is it so grenades are like it's not gay
if you're in a girl though
so think of an avocado is that a grenade
no that's way bigger than a grenade
grenade
around would you say grenades no not at
all look at that they're small
look at that yeah
that's the that's from commando and
that's the movies that that they're
pretty sure you can't fit that in a butt
you can definitely that's that they're
like that size if people are able to
look at that
feel smaller you can do that yeah you'll
throw it yeah so it fits in your hand
like
that
compare his hair that can go in your
butt pretty easily yeah i'm looking at
his hand
if a fist can go up there and a cell
phone can go up there for prison dude
i'm telling you
some of these girls really take on large
penises at the same time
why are you walking absolutely troopers
i don't know i guess just something got
to ease into i guess
apparently apparently that german guy
[Laughter]
okay this is a video over in albania
there's
a man in a car recklessly driving he was
actually under the influence of
narcotics
and he hit three cars while he was on
the road he then started to drive around
in this
public square where people kind of walk
around and a
pedestrian went try to help the
situation by jumping into his car
yeah both of his feet into the window
knocks the guy out
oh [ __ ] he knocked him out holy [ __ ]
that's way better where is this at you
albania oh everyone's all scared the
flying knee and the flying kick
shot i'm like damn ufc contract
boom boom that's better than anthony
pettis jump kick man that [ __ ] was
broken
that's kind of hard dog we got close up
oh wait he knocked him out yeah this is
before the knockout
it's right here this is close up right
here
boom [ __ ] damn it wow
he slapped him oh these they're about to
beat the [ __ ] i don't want you yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah we got
fire on his wheel
yeah dude he's slick yo kudos yeah
hell yeah god damn i was way better than
[ __ ] liu kang kick was sick
bruh he went hard with that [ __ ]
that [ __ ] was kind of hard
damn all right this is the one i showed
you a little bit earlier
a woman in indonesia jakarta was
swallowed by a 23 foot
python i was trying they was like nah
this is not
my neighbor's apartment uh that's a
little small ball python
it was like this is for real 23 feet
they found it later in the village and
they how big is it they killed it
23 feet it's yes that's huge yeah yeah
you're thinking you're saying ain't
grown in the wild they're they're
contracted to that little small
tank dog so i think still on the loose
though yeah we still haven't found it
someone commented on uh the video uh i
think like we posted
uh the behind the scenes thing
apparently they can get into the toilets
too so you gotta
be on the lookout bruh i
gotta check twice bro if you're a grown
man and you die from somebody's pet
snake you deserve to do what if i'm
taking a [ __ ] brendan
and then he sneak up bro you know how
hard that's going i got long
that thing would be easy to kill dude
all right bro
he see you saying it because he's not
the fastest if it's a rattlesnake
different animal yeah different have you
heard stories about people finding
snakes in like the toilet
a lot of them are fake though but some
are real some are yeah
and then this thing is still loose well
move
[Laughter]
you want me to do man [ __ ] leave
she's
before you go and how hard have you
really looked for this thing well we've
been
everyone like six units everyone have
been like talking about it
and no one's found it no one's found it
and we're all pissed off at it but
there's also a lot of like hawks and
[ __ ]
flying around hollywood so they they'll
eat the [ __ ] of that little [ __ ]
thing
a crow would there's a lot of crows oh
they'll destroy that [ __ ] horse
well yeah she hasn't bro you want to get
them out squirrels
uh rats when you think about it dude you
need a [ __ ] hollywood rat
uh-huh nothing is more gangster than a
failed
acting rat but that's not a ball python
though b
i mean listen i didn't say squirrels or
gangster i'm talking about raps
chappelle done with these soft ass
squirrels i'm talking about a real rat
dog
yeah i can take out those two you know i
love this girl no watch
they're quick as [ __ ] yeah they're quick
oh look at them tempting with the tail
holy [ __ ] this video is like eight
minutes long bro
i watch these kind of videos all the
time oh he's wearing them up
oh oh [ __ ] oh
[Music]
that snake ain't playing though he's
trying to get oh
snake running just go find a [ __ ]
walnut
this ain't worth it doug snakes get
exhausted does he eventually get him
nope nope squirrel had a bad day you
just want to take it out
i don't like squirrels dude uh release a
bunch of rabbits in your
apartment and see if it gets them out
like lure them out so we have rabbits
all over
that's what they like wait what what
does the owner feed it mice
uh well she no we haven't talked to her
like a lot of people are yelling at her
like for real she's getting it back
because big big white lady single
she's bad she's bad oh she's hot yeah
two dollars oh is there one directly
next door
yeah no you've seen her no i told him i
told you i was like yo
you told me yeah yeah all right game
plan here dude thank you
italian job here's what we're going to
do we're going to set up a little like
small area like just like maybe
we just set up like little parameters in
the in the baddies living room so you
got to be down there all the time
okay and then we're going to release
mice so
that's going to get him out that's going
to drag him out she said it's nowhere
near an apartment she lives in one
branch
she doesn't know you're right okay she's
not sure okay so we go down to the
apartment
you put you put mice in her apartment so
a you're down around that
bad [ __ ] all the time i like that but
then also put it in your apartment
and so hopefully one of the two drag
this [ __ ]
snake out what about my queen
what do you mean
but also it's not going to go for her
because you can go for the mice that's
what they like to eat
all right so what kind of mice white
mice yeah just go to your local pets
mart
pet city if they have them out here
shout out to pet city and roar colorado
shut down
but you could do that about a bunch of
lizards there can i just
can i just like if let's say i found
find a snake right how are you gonna
find it dude you can't find it let's say
it's in uh our apartment
then what i don't know anything about
snakes how i'm a container call the
baddie
call a baddie she knows how to contain
it okay all right i got that i like that
yeah i see it i saw what he did there
yeah okay
so then however submit to rate my state
with the snake
i like what you did there i got it i'm
gonna tell her that hell yeah let's see
you can see she's latin now she's i
don't know she's regular bro
i don't know let me put like this uh
what's the uh hawks the guy
uh who lives next door to us the pro
skater nigel
nigel houston all right so he has
parties all the time she's always there
oh that's how bad she is that's probably
why the snake got out
what do you mean she's partying all the
time oh yeah but she has two dogs though
she they so loud but she's like real
batty
and uh she's weird dude what if the dogs
ate that [ __ ]
no no they're small dogs dude here's the
small dog isn't it crazy because she's
hot you guys put up with it
yeah but she looked like a warlock you'd
call the cop i'll call the cops yeah
only the women are complaining i gotta
hear my girl guys
it's all good one guy's like i actually
like snakes
well that's how it is man if you're
attractive it's so much easier it's
easier i'm not gonna adore this other
guy
my apartment it's like we're already got
the mice you can i'm like no your girls
talking [ __ ]
yeah cause everyone's talking [ __ ] like
this is like an inconvenience for
everyone because you gotta walk on it's
only six units
and she's like i have she played loud
music she's cool
like i think she's dope but she sounds
like a guy i think she party i think she
died yeah she about it you see her oh
all right what else you got jen
excuse me um oh this one trailer falls
100 million
lawsuit over the piracy of the jake paul
fight i guess with that
eight or nine different websites that
are hosting it
because they're illegally streaming it
oh got it the lawsuit claims 12 online
sites are a full stream pay-per-view
fight between youtuber jake paul and mma
fighter ben askren
yeah so it so it's it equals like
millions of views
so you know dana's thinks they're full
of [ __ ] saying they sold like 1.5 or 2
million pay-per-views
they might have though just how big of a
following i honestly do
yeah i think i don't think that's too
far-fetched no no but i do think a
shitload of it was illegal
for sure because that's what the young
kids do man and that's why
uh [ __ ] espn and ufc has a
upper hand there because disney disney
don't [ __ ] around they're gonna lock
people down man
it's so it's someone that's i'm trying
to understand how like
they get into like streaming illegally
like is there
something like someone there that just
kind of like leaks it no
someone someone buys it and then puts it
up or you know
that's how they're doing like someone
like one person will buy it and then
put it into some sort of format
everybody can watch it no it's not
inside job
got it does espn not get along with
trilla or
yeah because i was wondering cause we
had that fight and he knocked him out it
was no highlights
no i mean espn yeah the espn's how you
can entertain that
did you see jake paul call out uzman
i mean i don't pay attention you know i
mean it's just it's what he you know i
i don't mind jake paul i'm friends with
logan i don't know jake that well but
it's like
uh i mean it's what he does yeah and
everyone buys into it it's like you guys
want to hate on the guy but you're all
eating up everywhere
yeah i was just saying like what what
who do you think would win like how dare
you
dude your score on short kings only or
where the [ __ ] it is
is so [ __ ] sharp crashing dude
you why i'm asking you you're i'm asking
your professional
opinion you're a professional question
so really oh let me just
entertain it so uzuma ufc fighter jake
paul who's been boxing for five years
straight
meeting the boxing ring and you're
saying would
mop the floor with him it wouldn't even
be a competition
mop the floor with them that's what
that's why i wanted to hear
i i thought that i just wanted a good
song anybody who doesn't know that
don't go on a date with them yeah yeah
if they bring that up on the short kings
only
you talk about karma osmond the best
welterweight ever
yeah who can [ __ ] box which is not
you know jake jake's been
boxing for five years camaro's been
fighting for 15
at a high high level yeah and knocking
dudes out in the ufc
i agree knocked out jorge mosvital
guilty
he pulled down that front hand and
smacked him i was a you beat the [ __ ]
out not even a fight
you're never gonna see it that fight's
never happening but also to dana's point
he's like dude you keep calling my guys
i'm gonna sue you
he's not cause he's in on it he's like
i'm gonna see you but like that those
fights can never happen yeah
let's get a dana white jake paul fight
going
do you like do you like this like
crossover though because i i like
i'm entertaining i'm sure i'm sure you
i'm sure you have the
floyd bring that up yeah i like it and
this is going to open a whole portal
to like youtubers and ufc fighters why
not so they're fighting
june 6 in miami at the har rock and
that's where the marlins play yes sir
mm-hmm play the trailer chin
is there let me go on this thing how
much bigger is uh low is it logan way
bigger well like 190
one yeah he he's not a small dude nah
and he's pretty tall yeah yeah
show time production son
i think you
but do they have now are they limited to
what like
like you know like with the exhibition
yeah usually the rounds are different it
won't i don't think it's 12 rounds like
they can't
they can't they can't go for knockouts
oh they can go for nothing
oh you can do it let's think about the
no it's just well it might be shorter
round
times and shorter like not 12 rounds it
won't be
uh was it three 12 rounds no it might be
two two minutes two minutes eight rounds
yeah yeah and that's easy oh two minutes
eight rounds oh that's light work for
you
is anyone in here more excited for this
than uh ascer and jake paul
nope unfortunately because i think
because ben asked and jake paul you
could paint the narrative there where
jake's fighting a real fighter for the
first time there was like this sense of
he might lose this one's interesting no
i still think it's gonna do over a
million buys yeah because of logan
and his but i think floyd should have
fought jake paul yeah
because jake paul wants fights but i
don't think jake but then i heard jake
paul doesn't want to fight for course
wants to continue to just like
uh annoy and piss off customers and try
to win easy because if you fight for
this jake's doing so i think jake's
doing it to actually
make money and compete and try to get
somewhere in the fight game yeah and
logan views this as this is a money grab
he's bigger
if he does land something you know like
he has nothing to lose
and but i do think like the narrative of
if floyd were to beat logan it makes the
jake paul fight even bigger
so you but but i heard i don't know but
jay leon was telling me
who the guy who was calling out your boy
tyrone willie oh
okay that's your guy yeah what's wrong
with him yeah what's wrong with him what
do you mean why is he talking [ __ ] to
woodley like that that's how he talks he
was just sorry talk okay put like this
let me just
hey you know what woodley would do to
him yeah yeah in a fight of course he
could beat his ass
he would beat up that entire room of
course i don't know like your boy's not
even
your boys are not in the air willie used
to train the wild card yeah but i spar
with wood yeah
good guy i like woodley but i'm just
saying jay leon this is how you so he
come up in the doghouse
and then you know for the fighters he he
was in
uh what's your ben ben's corner so when
you what you do before the fight you got
to go to your opponent's corner and see
if they're
like you know using illegal wraps yeah
you watch them wrap the head watch your
hands so
tyler so jake so jalen was just
basically saying man what you coming
over you don't know anything about these
bro you don't know come on
you don't know any things about these
champ and just playing with them you
know and he which he does it he was like
bro you don't even know anything about
boxing what you doing over here
and tyron woodley was like hey bro you
know i you know
who are you and we did that that's when
things just started shifting
i'm with woodley too listen i work for a
showtime i follow boxing i've never
heard of your friend
yeah jayla he was he signed to he was
assigned to floyd mayweather
is he probably i mean he's lost his last
two does he have google
he lost a beast though he lost uh your
boy uh david benavidez got
he got stopped by him and then uh peter
peter
killed chocolate so the legitimate guy
hey this guy's got wins
what's his record a 29 and three so no
no listen no he no he's a stun
listen the guys he lost to us but we're
not we're not talking about that's
woodley and him fighting boxing
we're talking about if he mouthed off in
that locker room woodley
would mop the floor with him yeah but i
think he just came in too hard
but that's how you play as a boxer he
but willie wasn't playing for one willie
was already annoyed
let's say you came in uh jake paul's
room and right and you everyone's just
like talking all that [ __ ]
and you already don't you don't like
jake paul and you see chappelle like hey
man you don't know nothing about these
gloves man come on
and you know you know what you're doing
over here just joking around and you
like what then he took it there then jay
leon took it there
he was basically saying like bro i was
messing with him you know what i mean i
get it
so willie just took it there so again i
can't i get what julian is saying he was
just messing around
if you know his character he's just a
playful guy but when you watch that
video
watch him play it he comes off as like
super like it's very jake paul ish vibe
well that's that's if you go but also
here's the other thing and i i don't
think what's the name jalen
i don't know he probably doesn't know
ufc right
like woodley's a walking legend he's a
beast yeah super beats
multi-time world champion bro uh he's
used to train with eric brown and
wildcard very nice very humble i love
that dude
so again it look i mean you but you
already know like when you
like those locker rooms it's already
intense it's like it's intense
atmosphere but that's what i'm saying
they so they're
listen jake paul locker room wasn't
intense they were playing you saw all
the celebrities
come back and stuff like they was just
playing around so tyron woodley came
over this
game time really mean business and he
was like oh [ __ ] what you what you know
about these champions
i think i think woodley meant more
business than ben askren again
yeah seriously and ben was like i don't
give a [ __ ] dude yeah and whether he's
like yes we do
we don't like this kid yeah yeah can i
see the video yeah so
yeah he's a scary guy he's the nicest
guy no but i mean not just a soldier
so and see if any ill tent
like jail came out his mind i thought it
was uh that was
i thought you looked like kids
man he laughed
[Music]
it's my dog
he's just coming in too hot like you
don't know woodley though huh like he
doesn't know woodley like that but he
called him champ and he was just playing
around here he called him
yeah he was he was just playing in
woolly took it there he's like you keep
going
he's champion
that's where he got pissed yeah yeah yep
exciting okay i don't
but they but they already they already
know he but at least i mean
willie's not coming at him he
and even in your world he's not big he's
not famous at all nobody knows who he is
nobody knows who he is so willie was
like wait hold on cuz he goes you don't
know if these woodley's like all right
cool
i'm the hall of fame dog and he's like
yeah he goes what's your name and he
tells me he's like
all right cool and then that's when he's
like yeah but i'll [ __ ] you up and
woodley's like all right
like he's he's the hostile one woodley's
just there to do his job
your boy kept coming at him and now and
99 of the world knows woodley
nobody knows your guy for sure but but
but that comment
this one this one uh it turned like you
know me well no the comment turned there
when he goes what's your name
no no not right before that no no he's
not bad when he went what's your name
no listen you can see jay leon stop
playing and go like who
when once he goes what's your name and
he tells me he was okay and then he had
to validate himself go
i'm signed by al hey man and then was it
yeah yeah
you're talking to a guy who's royalty
who's in the ufc hall of fame
and that's he was like yeah i'm running
the hall of fame dog he's like all right
i'm signed to al haymon that's when
that's when his ego got hit and that's
when he's like well and then he goes you
can't [ __ ] with me
all right and well he's like what jay
leon said this is this is him
before he was just joking so if you want
rewind that clip right i'm going to show
you where he got serious at
all right right see he's joking here
see that's fine i'm cool with that but
watch
it entirely
and that's where willy goes who are you
what's your name
yeah yeah yeah see look how serious your
boy is yeah he's serious but
but taiwan was stupid his ego got hit
though right yeah cause willie goes who
are you
oh yeah his ego got hit right there when
he said and then he was like you can't
[ __ ] with me well he's like
i'm naming him yeah because he said he
said you can't [ __ ] with me and then
will he say who who are you and that's
when his ego got hit
he was okay so this is what he's saying
i'm not and we can get off of it he said
he was like you don't know anything
about the east champ he was playing
there
and then willie said something he was
like what he was like bro do this too
that's when he switched so before no
that's where his but still
that's him because no one knows who he
is like who the [ __ ] are you yeah
he tried to like joke and then whitley
was all serious and then it's also
right before the fight yeah
i mean and nobody knows you so when you
come in joking with
he's like wait what who are you dude
yeah and that's where his ego got hit
and he's like you can't [ __ ] with me and
willie's like bro
yeah okay all right i got you all right
i tried to defeat you jay leon i'm sorry
it's your boy
he was in the wrong dude yeah yeah no
you definitely well he was basically
saying like bros just joking at least at
least we're talking about now because
i've never heard of them before that
so it worked i'm not even counting on
them there's a lot of good boxes out
that's boxing
yeah like no one knows anybody unless
you're really really famous
that's true yeah he came up from i know
him from floyd mayweather's camp and uh
he was floyd mayweather's like go-to guy
before tank came
and then uh he got knocked out and then
you know what happened when you get
knocked out you
you know you gotta get moved on but uh
so yeah that was all good
all right um so are we excited for floyd
uh
logan will you watch it chabelle
oh you don't really wanna care about
that i don't care you'll watch it right
i'll watch it yeah
but i think floyd's a minus 2 600
which i thought he i think he should be
minus 8 000. that big
i think so don't you yeah he's i mean
there's no way he's going to win
well here's the thing floyd like he
didn't okay it was a rumor i know you
heard about it he didn't
he didn't train for yeah okay okay i
heard that all right going into i heard
that he fought just like how he sparks
and he spars like that he walk him down
now with this guy logan he's
pretty much bigger i don't think he and
he's older and i'm hearing like yo floyd
is just like you know he's regular floyd
always stay in shape but he just
he just doesn't care anymore so i think
he's just gonna it's gonna be like eight
rounds it's gonna be a boring fight
and uh i think logan gonna survive all
right unless logan
we'll see but that's that's a win for
logan if he goes to decision with
her that's a win that's a win i don't
think mayweather has knockout power for
what globally i don't know
the only time he's going to knock him
out if logan paul gets tired that's what
floyd is basically yeah so i don't think
that because i see i think a problem
with saying floyd don't have knockout
power you're talking about him against
canelo or these other monsters or you
know
against a uh logan paulian
yeah because logan paul never been like
tested before but i think floyd is gonna
stop hit him with a lot of body shots
and i think he's not gonna take out any
risk
and you know it's a wild fight it's like
an amateur fighter fighting you but but
i do
but i do think floyd is an entertainer
so he he's gonna put on a show those
early rounds
and then that's why i think he's not
gonna train if he trained hard he is
stopping but he's not going to he's not
going nah you know it's a money group
but the narrative is why i think people
buy it because in this crazy world we
live in right which 2021 is nuts
what if logan landed atlanta one yeah
that's so dumb and floyd's not gonna
give up but what would happen he's not
like let's say he wobbled him like dude
and then what logan's going sizzler
you'd wobble floyd it would be like
the world would [ __ ] oh boxing would
be like holy [ __ ] okay let me actually
that should be a bet chance that's the
bet
those are where you're gonna make your
money you're gonna make money on a minus
[ __ ] four thousand
exactly okay and i i don't think he's
gonna land anything that's flo you
understand the master but yeah that's
what i was gonna say i was like there's
a lot of people that didn't like now now
go back to what you're talking about him
prime getting ready for a fight
and if he sleeps on logan it's just it's
weird
he's not gonna sleep on them also you
gotta look at like floyd's history
he like people like he fights on timing
someone like wild like that he just [ __ ]
up go
look at madonna yeah gave him more so
you thought and logan don't throw them
crazy punches
so he might land something but it's not
gonna be like cause you
you think logan's gonna go for the
knockout oh logan hey that's all he can
do yeah it's a load
what's looking good back and try and
pick him apart
that's not even an option dude if i if
i'm logan's camp i'm i'm
all we're doing is you go for a broke
those first three rounds whatever
happens after then you get stopped great
but
gopher [ __ ] broke dude yeah like come
out like a banshee for three does anyone
came back
from adoption but but
you can i to me in this fight you can't
even reference madonna no because canelo
like you're talking about
skills you're talking about legit
[ __ ] real high caliber boxes but if
you
logan's the the he's the he's the
[ __ ]
you know cheat code where it's this wild
we have no idea what to expect
yeah and you gotta hope that weirdness
lands up on floyd
and that's why people are going to buy
it
what you laughing it's just [ __ ]
watching it's not tired
it's crazy but so that that's what
drives my point do you like this
night it's turning the bus i think
there's a lot i think there's a lane for
it
i think there's a lane for you yeah
there's definitely a lane for it i know
people
hate on it bro i love these fights i'm
more excited for these kind of fights
than like we were talking in the green
room like yeah i care about terence
crawford and earl spins because i know
those guys but
i'm more excited for like a jake paul
versus someone else
because it's so [ __ ] wild i'm not
more i like i'm more the most
i'm excited for is joshua versus fury
and that's real box
but there's a lane for this and i think
where box and mma
the haters they get confused because
they look at it
i don't like i stopped looking at the
same a long time ago i'm like that's
what you guys want to do do it man you
don't have
people want to pay and watch who gives a
[ __ ] i don't get off the hate
yeah i think yeah but he gets more
attention than canelo all right that's
the market value
but that's his fan base those aren't
real boxing heads who were buying it
that's yeah
this is his fan base him and his brother
could compete in [ __ ] checkers and
they'd buy it millions of people would
buy yeah they decided to do this
yeah you just got to separate the two a
lot of people can't separate
so yeah i like the lane that's going
like honestly next fight with that
logan and paul i think they should have
all kind of youtube fighters versus
boxers as well
let's get tank versus you know i mean
ksi
i don't want to go there no i don't want
to go there because then then you will
get the hate
i think you gotta do like floyd's
obviously retired and he's fighting a
youtuber
it makes sense retired and he's not even
a boxer fighting jake paul
like you you yeah i think you got to
keep it a circus once you start dabbling
and you get like
real production and real commentators
and real boxers then then that's where
the lines get blurred
and that's where all the hate comes from
but but but so i guess this
celebrity youtuber stuff there's a lane
perfect example like just like a youtube
fight league
i get what you say look jayden i love
good fighter never had that kind of
exposure you throw him on the card
no one knows who he is exactly but but
no we're not trying to see him
that's it no one's paying because if you
get a guy nobody knows he's like yeah he
was going gloves champ two on seven like
what the [ __ ] he fighting
you know this ksi for yeah yeah it has
to be two really big names for people
what if what if you get a jailing
love versus a real like like a real
boxing match and people but i don't
think
people watch like those like a jake paul
versus been asked uh
ben a lot of fighters wasn't watching
for like that that
real boxing i don't want like like your
boy uh what's his name uh pettigrew uh
regis
regis like they shouldn't put real
boxing thank you that's what i'm saying
it throws off the cards you leave it a
circus like that
everybody enjoys the circus those fights
before were ridiculous
yeah yes and he faked the body shot like
yesterday
leave that there there was a [ __ ] of
blood that fought that's wildlife
yeah yeah exhausted
[Music]
walmart is accusing kanye of copying
their logo and i'll show you
there's two right here oh wow huh
i mean it's not like it's original
walmart like that's a [ __ ]
flower dude when i turn on my computer
that's the button
[Laughter]
i look like the cactus jack logo a
little bit with travis none of it none
of it's
so yeezy's proposed logos on the left
compared to one or two i mean dude it's
not
none of that's original yeah all right
let's see
that's like when lebron tried
trademarking taco tuesday
it's friends you can't do that
[Laughter]
what did you get uh this so lebron's in
the news because of his
post about that police officer that shot
the girl yeah he said your neck
yeah then you took it down um so this
officer
is actually wanting to sit down with
lebron and this is a black police
officer as well
but no obviously that's not going to
happen but then that leads us to this
here where they're not going to sit down
with them they say rizzo
i think he just knows he's wrong yeah he
knows yeah
he's back oh he's just like oh i'm
taking i'll take the l because even nike
was like what the [ __ ] are you doing
take that down bro the whole entire woke
left was like all right this
is a little much yeah yeah this skit
this
i guess it's a skit that's a real police
officer doing this and this is him
you know how lebron said you know that
the police officer shouldn't have shot
that
girl you know but does a black girl
attack another black girl play this
dispatch i've arrived at that
disturbance we have lebron call my cell
phone right away please thank you
excuse me sir excuse me no can you put
the knife down please sir
no no no sir don't stab it no no stop
stab
stop hold on hold on it's lebron
hey you got me again listen i'm out here
at this disturbance call and there's a
guy trying to stab another guy with a
knife what do you think i should do what
does that mean
okay uh well they're both black one
guy's trying to stab another guy with a
knife
deadly force is completely justified
i see so you don't care if a black
person kills another black person
but you do care of a white cop
even if he's doing it to save the life
of another black person i mean it
doesn't make a whole lot of sense
and again you are really good at
basketball so i guess i'll take your
word for it
okay all right thanks lebron michael
jordan's the goat
as well you are really good at
basketball so i'm going to take your
word for it
it's so ridiculous sylvester who's the
best oh the guy that's the cop
back in yep um yeah not much else really
this is
interesting i thought a race dog that
won a competition
test deposit from meth i bet that
[ __ ] was
moving right wait they said it won they
won yeah
dog's name was zipping sarah yeah
secured first place yeah on [ __ ]
meth yeah how did it always on math they
they testing those
oh wow they test yeah why would she have
dog meth if they're getting [ __ ]
urine tested
four months bad gotta be that's not bad
yeah that's it four months there's only
four thousand dollars about 3 500
in fines as well so she lost bread
that's what you do when you give your
dog meth did you just inject the mess or
does the dog smoke the mouth do you
smoke your bloating
apparently dogs get high like if you
blow it in the ear i don't know how true
that is it's just
really hard yeah that's something that's
some high bro i've heard that before
yeah did she just shut his little wet
nose and mouth and blow right in his
nose
so the meth goes right into it that dog
was like oh
[ __ ] we've got to win i'm not gonna stop
it
my heart is racing do you think that dog
is addicted to meth depending
probably i've been doing this for a
while what's your thing graphics too
yeah i got them oh yeah what's your this
is just remember what you said he's
addicted to man
i said what if oh you think i don't know
how many times well this first time they
got busted
yeah and he's always if you do it
consistently to make money off
yeah he'll be addicted he's gonna need
that you know it gives you energy
shrooms
troops shrooms yeah yeah like yo you get
you can run all non-stop
like fast for a long time my god last
weekend
you know i was talking to my homegirl
she was like yo i did shrooms and i
literally
ran off didn't stop running yeah
i didn't know that you have a lot of
stories where it's your home girl
i know right i got a lot of girls i feel
like it's you
oh man well we're in lexington kentucky
next week thursday friday saturday may
6th through the 8th lexington kentucky
let me know where to go for the uh
whiskey tours
uh my boy whiskey pizza but let me know
if you guys don't good places to eat
may 6th to the 8th that's next week all
those shows are damn near sold out
and then houston texas is may 20th
through the 22nd
houston texas houston improv oklahoma
city oklahoma june 10th through the 12th
get your tickets at f a t k z dot com
chappelle's in philly next week yeah
philly next week may
6 through the 8th comedy club bro
i need those [ __ ] philly cheese
sticks i need a legit spot like
everyone keeps like don't throw too many
references i'm telling you just go to
our my boys at uh suplex
that's all you need to go to don't
listen to anybody just go to them just
go to them
get shoes and a nice philly cheesesteak
all right and then may 13th through 15th
i'll be a good night's comedy club in
raleigh north carolina
raleigh north carolina uh tickets at
your palace
calm and that's the first time i [ __ ]
up a word i think that's not because
y'all [ __ ] up all the time
yeah welcome welcome welcome bro
how are you all right hell yeah bro it's
official now
hi kids we're out see you friday